Merci de rester là jusqu'à la toute fin.
C'est beaucoup de choses à apprendre dans très peu de temps.
Je voulais à nouveau commencer par la Père.
Seigneur, nous sommes tellement reconnaissants que tu es notre Père.
Nous te remercions que tu nous as aimé, que tu nous as adopté et que tu nous as fait appartenir à toi.
Nous te remercions pour ta bonté de nous avoir réunis dans ce lieu pour un moment comme celui-là.
Et nous prions que le Seigneur Jésus soit exalté.
Je prie que mes sœurs soient encouragées.
Seigneur, que tu nous fasses des femmes d'amour et de bonté et de courage.
Que tu montres à chaque femme ici présente comment elle doit servir.
Et c'est tout pour ta gloire.
En nom de Jésus.
Amen.
Lors de nos deux premières sessions, nous avons vu comment nous sommes appelés à être des aides pour nos maris.
Pendant qu'eux dirigent notre famille.
Et ensuite, comment nous sommes appelés à être des aides quand nous encourageons nos maris dans leur ministère.
Dans cette dernière session, je voudrais parler avec vous sur comment nous pouvons servir directement dans l'Église de Dieu.
D'abord, je voudrais partager avec vous les peuples positions que les femmes sont restriquées au rôle des femmes dans l'Église.
Dans le Nouveau Testament, nous trouvons que Jésus a traité toutes les femmes avec dignité.
Même les femmes qui étaient considérées des exclus sociales.
Mais il est aussi très clair que Dieu a désigné la leadership masculine pour son Église.
Il y a plusieurs passages dans les Écritures qui réservent sans équivoque certains rôles d'enseignement et de gouvernance dans l'Église aux hommes.
Et j'aimerais que vous tournez avec moi dans le passage principal concernant la soumission des femmes et le leadership dans l'Église.
1 Timothy 2, verses 12-14.
Et je vais donc vous lire 1 Timothy 2, verses 12-14.
Je ne permets pas à la femme d'enseigner ni de prendre l'autorité sur l'homme.
Mais elle doit demeurer dans le silence.
Car Adam a été formé le premier, Ève ensuite.
Et ce n'est pas Adam qui a été séduit.
C'est la femme qui, séduite, s'est rendue coupable de transgression.
Maintenant, c'est important pour nous de rappeler que le contexte de cet enseignement était l'Église rassemblée.
Wherever Christians might gather for teaching and worship and prayer.
C'est-à-dire que tous les entrants, les Chrétiens peuvent se regrouper, se réunir pour l'enseignement et pour la prière.
Immediately following this passage, we have the requirements for elders.
Which plainly reserves the office for men.
So women are not permitted to teach men in the church.
Donc aux femmes, il n'est pas permis d'apprendre aux hommes dans l'Église.
Or to have governing authority in the church.
Ni à exercer une autorité de direction dans l'Église.
This does not mean that a woman cannot teach men other things.
Cela ne veut pas dire qu'une femme ne peut pas apprendre ou enseigner à un homme d'autre chose.
A Christian woman can teach a man math.
Or a foreign language.
Or how to play a musical instrument.
Une femme chrétienne peut apprendre à un homme des mathématiques.
Ou une langue étrangère.
Ou comment jouer un instrument de musique.
They just are not permitted to teach men the Bible in the church.
Elles ne sont juste pas autorisées à apprendre ou à enseigner aux hommes la Bible dans l'Église.
Now we know that this teaching was not temporary and it was not cultural, as some would tell us.
We know that because it was based on the order of creation.
Nous savons ça parce que l'argument est basé sur l'ordre de la création.
The Apostle Paul's reasoning in the second chapter of 1 Timothy was that women were not permitted to teach men or to usurp authority over men
because Adam was formed first and then he.
Le raisonnement de l'apôtre Paul dans le passage qu'on a vu est que les femmes ne veulent pas enseigner aux hommes ni usurper l'autorité sur eux dans l'Église
parce qu'Adam a été formé en premier.
And the man was not deceived, but the woman was.
Et l'homme n'a pas été séduit, mais c'est la femme qui a été séduit.
By basing his directive on the order of creation and the way Adam and Eve individually transgressed,
it's obvious that this applies to all churches for all time.
Also, in perfect submission to his father's will, Jesus personally appointed, chose, and trained twelve apostles.
He could have chosen six women and six men.
Or he could have chosen ten men and two women.
But he did.
He only chose men to hold that position of authority.
Throughout the Old and New Testaments, we only see men teaching the assembled body of God's people.
Dans tout l'Ancien Testament, nous ne voyons que des hommes qui enseignent à des assemblées de personnes.
We only see men governing over the church.
Nous ne voyons que des hommes qui gouvernent l'église.
En fait, nous n'avons aucun exemple de la Genèse à l'apocalypse d'une femme qui enseigne publiquement un groupe assemblée ou un peuple d'éthiènes.
Nous n'avons pas un seul exemple d'une femme qui sert comme un pasteur ou un ancien d'une congrégation.
Consequently, I only see two restrictions on women serving in the local church.
Par conséquent, je ne vois que deux restrictions pour les femmes qui servent dans la réglise locale.
Lorsqu'il y a un groupe de chrétiens assemblés, les femmes ne doivent pas enseigner aux hommes.
Nor should they exercise authority over the men in the church.
Donc cela signifie bien sûr qu'elles ne doivent pas occuper le rôle de pasteur ou d'ancien dans une église.
Mais il y a tellement plus de choses que les femmes peuvent et doivent faire au sein de la réglise locale.
Et c'est sur cela que je voulais focaliser dans cette dernière session.
Je veux que nous considérons comment nous pouvons être des aides fidèles dans l'église.
J'ai huit petits-enfants très précieux.
Et j'aime quand ils sont tous chez moi.
Ils ont des âges entre 11 et 5 ans.
Donc c'est un peu le chaos.
Mais je l'aime.
Et une chose que j'ai remarqué quand tous mes petits-enfants sont ensemble et qui jouent ensemble.
Ils peuvent avoir des jouets tout autour d'eux.
Mais ils vont toujours vouloir celui que l'autre a.
Et vous savez, il y a des fois où nous sommes pas si différents de petits-enfants, n'est-ce pas ?
Vous nous dites que nous ne pouvons pas avoir quelque chose et c'est ce qu'on va vouloir.
Et c'est facile de se concentrer sur les peu de restrictions que nous avons dans la parole de Dieu.
Et négliger toutes les merveilleuses opportunités que nous avons de servir.
Nous voyons qu'il y a un très grand nombre de femmes qui ont joué un rôle simple.
C'est significatif dans le ministère du Christ.
Beaucoup de femmes l'ont suivi et adoré et servi Jésus.
C'était une femme qui a lavé ses pieds avec ses cheveux.
C'est une femme qui a trouvé le tombeau vide pour la première fois.
Elle a été la première à annoncer qu'elle a été ressuscité.
Nous pouvons lire plein d'histoires des femmes courageuses qui ont amené l'évangile à d'autres endroits.
Les femmes ont continué à avoir un impact, un impact de l'évangile à travers les siècles.
J'ai lu une histoire qui m'a beaucoup touchée.
C'était par rapport à une femme qui s'appelle Joanne Shetler.
Elle était une missionnaire avec Wycliffe Bible Translators et elle a servi aux Philippines.
Elle raconte d'un homme dans son village qui l'a adopté en tant que fille.
Il était en train de traduire les pages du Nouveau Testament dans leur langage.
Elle a dit qu'un jour, lorsqu'ils tradisaient la Bible ensemble, ils sont arrivés à un verset en 1er Timothée.
Et elle a dit que le verset disait que les femmes ne doivent pas enseigner aux hommes.
Elle a dit que mon papa n'a même pas cligné les yeux.
Mais cet après-midi-là, après qu'ils avaient fini notre travail, il m'a regardé et il m'a posé la question suivante.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va étudier ce dimanche?
Je pensais qu'il était simplement curieux, donc je lui ai dit.
Mais le dimanche matin, avant qu'elle puisse se lever et commencer à enseigner à la congregation, c'est lui qui s'est levée.
Il a dit, ma fille ici, elle sait plus que moi par rapport à ce que nous allons voir.
Mais nous avons trouvé dans la Bible que les femmes ne devaient pas enseigner les gens la Bible.
Je trouve dans les Écritures que les femmes ne doivent pas enseigner la Bible aux hommes.
Donc je pense que c'est moi qui dois le faire.
Et elle dit, c'était la fin de ma carrière en tant qu'enseignante.
Et le début de leur apprentissage et d'établissement d'une église.
J'aime cette histoire.
Parce que c'est une belle image, une belle image de la réponse adaptée aussi de l'homme que de la femme à ce que la Bible enseigne.
Joanne's daddy did not make excuses for his inadequacy.
Le papa de Joanne n'a pas cherché des excuses à son insuffisance.
And she did not demand that she be allowed to continue to teach just because she was more learned than he was.
And she did not demand that she was the one who continued to teach just because she was more than he was.
They both individually bound to the authority of the Scripture.
Ils se sont tous les deux de leur côté soumis à l'autorité de la parole de Dieu.
And it was a key turning point in the establishing of a congregation with male leadership employees.
Et c'était un point très important dans l'établissement de leadership dans cette congregation.
Now there are several things that every Christian woman should be engaged in.
Maintenant il y a plusieurs choses que toutes les femmes chrétiennes doivent être ou elles doivent s'impliquer.
Every child of God has been blessed with at least one spiritual gift.
Chacun fin de Dieu a été béni avec au moins un don spirituel.
And you should be using those gifts to serve God and his people.
Et vous devez utiliser ces dons-là pour servir à Dieu et son peuple.
We are all called to pray.
Nous sommes toutes appelés à prier.
Every one of us is responsible to read and study and memorize and meditate on the Scripture.
Chacun d'entre nous est responsable de lire et d'étudier et d'apprendre par cœur et de méditer dans les Écritures.
We all share the duty as well as the privilege of evangelizing the lost.
Nous partageons tout le devoir ainsi que le privilège d'évangéliser.
And according to Titus chapter 2,
All the godly older women should be in some way teaching, training, mentoring, discipling young women.
Et selon Titus chapter 2,
Toutes les femmes croyantes doivent être, d'une certaine façon ou d'une autre,
En train d'enseigner, de former, d'accompagner et encadrer les jeunes femmes.
And most of us can be giving something financially to the church.
Et la plupart d'entre nous peuvent contribuer financièrement à l'Église.
So all Christians are called to do some things.
Donc tous les chrétiens sont appelés à faire certaines choses.
I want to encourage those of you with young children to never view your children as a distraction from real ministry.
Je veux encourager certaines d'entre vous avec de petits enfants de ne jamais voir vos enfants comme une distraction du vrai ministère.
As C.S. Lewis famously said,
Children are not a distraction from more important work.
Comme C.S. Lewis a dit,
C'est très connu,
Les enfants ne sont pas une distraction du travail plus important.
They are the most important work.
Ils sont le travail le plus important.
Parce que vous n'allez jamais impacter autant de vie comme celle des enfants que par en les façonnant et les modelant chaque jour.
Donc celles qui ont encore des enfants à la maison doivent se rendre pour les enfants.
Je ne me rends compte que c'est un ministère très important en soi-même.
Those of us who are married need to be careful not to neglect our responsibility to help our husbands as we've looked at.
Celles d'entre nous qui sont mariés ne peuvent pas négliger la responsabilité d'aider nos maris comme nous avons déjà vu.
Now one thing I want to make clear is that I am not saying that you cannot be involved in any other ministry when you have younger children.
I am just encouraging you not to neglect that vital ministry during the limited time that you have with them.
There are so many things women can do in the church.
We can publicly share testimonies of God's work in our lives as well as the lives of others.
We can share publicly what God does in our lives and in the lives of other people.
We can sing or play musical instruments.
Well I can't sing or play musical instruments.
But some of you can.
We can sing with a group like a choir or play in an orchestra or we can sing individually.
We can sing individually.
Women can write semi-school material.
We can sing as a school material.
They can sing as church secretaries and treasurers.
They can sing as secretaries or treasurers for the church.
They can sing as doctors and nurses in remote places.
They can sing as doctors or inferiors in places in places very...
...
!